foch le commandant suprême interallié
avait exigé que les alliés entre
immédiatement dans la bataille l'anglais
n'était pas convaincu et dans essuyé des
pertes sévères à la bataille des
flandres qu'il avait si mal conduite
mais un de ses adjoints le général
rawlinson 1 chez des rats la tête de
drogue avait un plan plus précis il
prétendait obtenir la percée dans le
secteur damien avec sa 4ème armée feu
vert le foch qui n'hésite pas à soutenir
le général britannique
même s'il prend des risques fauche a
toujours été le parti en fougue de
l'offensive 17 divisions 2000 canon 450
tang se rassemblent sur un front de 25
km rien que pour déplacer artillerie il
faut 60 trains
à
on
pour que la surprise soit complète les
anglais font une choses insensées 800
avions décollent pour que le bruit de
leurs moteurs recouvre celui des camions
sur les routes
pègre réunit tous les effectifs
disponibles en grattant des unités sur
tout le front comme on grimpe le fond de
ses poches 600 chars sont prêts à
démarrer presque l'intégralité du royal
british temps cops du canadian cops de
l'australian coach nataf fixé 8 août
la charge est irrésistible les 500 yards
de no man's land sont franchies par la
4ème armée en un quart d'heure les chars
fournissent un précieux appui aux unités
d'assaut la division canadienne nettoie
les tranchées allemandes à midi
à la droite de l'armée anglaise deux
armées françaises attaques vers l'est
elle réalise un bond en avant de 15 km
les allemands n'ont plus de réactions il
laisse se développer l'offensive
un général de division allemand et
capturer la retraite de l'ennemi été
ordonnée ce qui n'est pas dans ses
habitudes
la voie ferrée paris amiens est
complètement dégagé ce qui va permettre
le ravitaillement des armées du nord
les alliés s'arrête prudemment après
leur succès pour ménager leur homme est
reconstitué leurs forces
le mend a enfin fait ses comptes
il ne peut plus gagner les soldats
allemands ont fait un effort
considérable pendant les dernières
offensives
déçu affamés ils ne croient plus en la
victoire
les compagnies sont décimés les
bataillons réduits à des effectifs
squelettiques le 8 août dès le 2 nov
c'est le jour de deuil de l'armée
allemande ce jour-là il offre sa
démission au keyser qui la refusent
le dender fordo de la retraite et les
villes françaises libérées explose de
joie
on oublie tous les destructions les
bombardements on ne voit plus que les
alliés vainqueurs
bon
clemenceau le pieux patriot vient au
front pour éprouver comme il dit la
grandeurs et les misères de la victoire
la guerre est trop sérieuse des et il
pourrait être confiée à des militaires
ils se rendent à soissons pour y
célébrer la victoire
près du champ de bataille parlant
parfaitement l'américain il va dans les
lignes des deux boys et aussi près
d'amiens chez les autres jacques le
vieux sceptique a la dent dure
mais il sait tous ce qu'il doit aux
alliés
ans
dans le camp allié en septembre 1918
le moral est au beau fixe mais avec des
réserves
on se souvient des emballements
irraisonnée des espoirs déçus des
offensives avortées l'ennemi attend
derrière la ligne siegfried dont les
défenses sont formidables les
états-majors n'attendent pas la victoire
avant le printemps 2009 119 ils se
résignent à voir leur solde a passé un
nouvel hiver dans l'étranger ils ne
s'attendent pas au dégel rapide du front
allemand
les américains décident de se lancer eux
mêmes dans une offensive la reconquête
d'un secteur qui est un saillant dans la
ligne du front allemand
ils lancent dans un bataille des
effectifs déjà très entraînés mais aussi
des deux boys qui n'avait pas du tout
l'expérience du feu l'opération réussit
néanmoins parfaitement au prix il est
vrai de pertes très élevé les américains
étaient les seuls à pouvoir attaquer
français et anglais était à bout de
souffle les prisonniers allemands sont
nombreux
non
sami yen les allemands te laisse aux
secteurs de lorraine depuis trois ans
désormais les américains que pleuville
leur offensive sur le saillant a
pleinement réussi
à
l'imprenable saillants de saint mihiel a
été entièrement reconquis en quelques
heures par l'infanterie américaine
il n'y aura plus dans cette petite ville
de lorraine de plaques de rues in the
box 3 1
sur l'argonne vers mézières pershing
accepte parfaitement le plan français
mais il prétend garder son indépendance
celle d'une armée qui vient de faire ses
preuves à saint mihiel
pershing est de plus en plus décidé à
conduire la bataille d'une manière
indépendante tout en s'intégrant dans le
dispositif des armées alliées coordonné
par foch
l'état major américain s'est conduite de
manière irréprochable au cours des
dernier engagement les troupes
américaines sont allés droit au but sans
se mélanger aux unités voisines
quand fauche expose son plan d'offensive
pershing refuse d'avoir ses divisions
éparpillés entre les armées française et
britannique
il veut attaquer d'un seul bloc
voulez vous battre oui ou non lui
demande foch sans doute mais dans une
armée américaine répond pershing
j'insiste dit foch insisté tant que vous
voudrez je refuse absolument alors perçu
une choisi son secteur sur la carte il
décide de se conformer au plan alliés
qui prévoit de pousser les divisions
françaises et américaines droits sur
l'allemagne à travers l'art code et la
lorraine
pendant que des groupements français
percevront en direction de valenciennes
la ligne hindenburg père chine veut plus
que jamais rester indépendant il se
battra dans l'argonne entre les grands
bois et les collines boisées de
l'argonne et la rivière meuse sur les
champs de bataille maintes fois
retournés par les canons allemands au
cours de la bataille de verdun
une bataille qui a duré près d'un an
pendant l'année 1916 un secteur vital
pour l'offensive alliée
car il contient une voie ferrée
stratégique
les allemands en face sont enterrés
profondément dans le confort relatif des
bunkers d'hérodote d abri bétonné
ils ont un système de défense très bien
conçu sur une profondeur d'environ 25
kilomètres les abris sont si profonds
qu'il ne faut pas espérer les faire
sauter avec des tirs d'artillerie
les allemands jouent aux cartes dans
leur schollen ils s'ennuient et leur
chef bout d'impatience de se mesurer aux
américains c'est le prince héritier
frederik d'ignobles kron prince
il ne peut pas savoir que les
combattants américains sont plus d'un
million au front ils ont leurs propres
réseaux d'approvisionnement depuis les
ports français à travers tout le
territoire
une armée autonome et fraîche une force
redoutable devant les effectifs fatigué
du conte prince qui ne peut attendre de
nouveaux renforts
parmi les américains qui roulent dans
camion vers l'argonne le colonel george
patton 32 ans qui a reçu dans un char
français le baptême du feu à saint
mihiel deux jeunes officiers de marine
futur commandant du corps
thomas ce volcan b clifton gates le
capitaine art et romane 34 ans qui
commande une batterie d'artillerie à
cheval et son futur chef d'état major le
colonel georges marchal 37 ans chargé
par pershing de la logistique sa mission
est d'organiser le mouvement en deux
jours de 600 mille tonnes avec les
canons et les munitions la nourriture
pour la troupe et pour la cavalerie des
tonnes d'équipement et de matériel
médical pour faire mouvement trois
routes étroites que l'apu a rendu plus
un vote
moi
les doutes bas ils retrouvent les
vieilles tranchées françaises de verdun
creuser deux ans plus tôt et par boucher
cinq cent mille soldats sont alignés sur
40 kilomètres de front ils sont trop
nombreux ils se gênent ils vont se
marcher sur les pieds lors de l' attaque
ils sont une cible idéale pour
l'artillerie ennemie mais l'aviation les
protège 800 avions qui assurent la
couverture de francs et bombardent sans
cesse les lignes allemandes
la première armée américaine est prête
pour le grand bond en avant
26 septembre 1918
bon
à droite et au centre de la ligne
américaine les collines de montfaucon
les ordres sont de s'en emparer à tout
prix mais le feu et demi est très
efficace et empêche les américains de
s'élever d'un bon jusqu'au sommet il
faut deux jours pour 130 remettre et les
pertes sont nombreuses parmi les
assaillants dont beaucoup n'ont jamais
vu le feu
sur l'ailé gauche les américains doivent
nettoyer avec des chars les bois de
l'argonne travail fastidieux et très
dangereux car chaque fourré peut cacher
un une mitrailleuse un mortier et même
adresse flammes
chaque mètre pour les soldats qui avance
est à partir
pendant que les yankees c'est 8 sur le
front meuse à redonne les britanniques
ouvre une nouvelle offensive vers le
nord tournant par surprise la ligne
siegfried les deux offensives anglaises
et l'américaine pourrait converger
encerclant les allemands l'état major
français estimé que père chine ne
pouvait commencer ce mouvement avant le
printemps
ici dans l'argonne par le moindre indice
de brèche dans le dispositif allemand ce
que les français ne voient pas c'est
qu'à l'arrière des lignes le front
allemand est en train de craquer à
l'hôtel de spa en belgique qui sert de
quartier général un lieu d'or le
quartier-maître général regarde
attentivement la carte de feront ils
preuve avec ses draps ce froid
il comprend que tout est perdu il
rencontre le caire avec hindenburg pour
exiger une demande d'armistice et puis
il retourne à son quartier général pour
essayer de te dire et d'obtenir les
conditions de paix des plus avantageuses
possible le front allemand de l'argonne
est aussitôt renforcée devant les
américains
ouais
au fond les yankees ont perdu leur
esprit impétueux ils sont devenus amer
en six semaines d'une bataille féroce
ils ont en quelques semaines connu
toutes les peler de 4 ans d'enfer
ils sont tués par les éclats de bus et
de grenades affichée par les
mitrailleuses gaz est atteint par le
virus de la grippe espagnole à raison de
11 mille par semaine des blessés encore
des blessés et aussi des morts
en octobre 10 118 les américains ont
perdu leur enthousiasme il hiverne aussi
tristement que leurs camarades français
britanniques belges canadiens portugais
blackjack pertes chine est désespérée a
rien ne va comme il veut il considère le
retard de l'offensive comme un échec
personnel
il assume propre tâche il ne maîtrise
plus il a la charge d'une zone de guerre
avec ses problèmes tactiques et
stratégiques mais aussi de la ligne des
renforts et des approvisionnements
beaucoup d'américains sont occupés dans
la logique cité mais sans plan précis
le résultat c'est le chaos les enfants
mal reçus les hôtes contradictoires le
soutien d'artillerie qui vient trop tard
qu'ils tombent sur les lignes a mis les
problèmes de communication dans une
armée gigantesque de près de deux
millions de do it boy dont l'immense
majorité ne parle pas un mot de français
certaines unités se divisent d'autres
avancent pro vie certaines sont en
retard on voit des bataillons viré de
bord et se mêler à des divisions où il
n'était nullement prévu un général exige
de la military police
une ligne continue à l'arrière pour
empêcher les désertions
comme l'offensive américaine ne parvient
pas à mordre sur la ligne allemande
on commence à dire à paris et à londres
que le show des dum boys tourner au flop
car on parle déjà le franglais au café
de la paix
il faut tout réorganiser rien ne va plus
chez les américains les rations les
munitions n'arrive pas au front le
département de la guerre a averti perche
et il m'a nommé un responsable de la
logistique de gradés de pouvoirs égaux
aux siens père chine réagit aussitôt
phénomène général james herbert tu en
qui il a confiance herbert et sous ses
ordres
sur le champ de bataille il désigne deux
responsables pour chacune des armées
américaines
poulter les gâte pour la première
les bollaert dans la seconde le premier
d'or les traités de stratégie le second
les beaux uniformes
un ami octobre et yom qui font la pause
dans l'argot pour retrouver leur souffle
la crise du ravitaillement ne fait
qu'embellir
en
les colonnes de ravitaillement sont sous
le feu de l'ennemi il connaît chaque
route de ce secteur qu'il a si longtemps
occupé et ses canaux frappent à coup sûr
moi
oh
non
partout ailleurs sur le front français
l'armée allemande s'écroule mais devant
les américains al kanz coup un protège
ainsi en tenant les débouchés des
défilés de l'argonne sa retraite vers le
nord quand les normes qui s'apprête à
lancer leur nouvelle offensive du 1er
novembre
il n'y a pas encore le moindre signe de
reddition
dans le secteur mais argol comme
ailleurs sur le front
la dégradation de la guerre va de pair
avec l'héroïsme obscur des individus le
sergent alvin york était objecteurs de
conscience dans le tennessee converti
incorporait il avait à lui seul
maîtriser un poste de mitrailleuses
allemand avec son pistolet sa carabine
ils avaient capturé 132 prisonniers le
major charles souhaite le cdh dont le
bataillon s'était avancé trop loin et
trop tôt devait rester encerclé pendant
cinq jours ils s'étaient dégagés sauvant
la moitié de son unité qui porte
désormais à nos héroïques
le bataillon perdu
à des officiers les plus décorés de la
guerre que pershing appelé le meilleur
conducteur d'hommes était le brigadier
général douglas macarthur alors âgé de
38 ans qui obtenait son premier
commandement important en prenant la
tête de la 42e division mais six autres
généraux ont été remplacés pour faute
professionnelle ou dépression nerveuse
dans le terrible ouragan de la bataille
75000 américains avaient été tués ou
blessés ici dans l'argonne plus que sur
aucun autre champ de bataille de l'armée
américaine ils sont tombés dans
l'argonne aux dernières heures de la
guerre
alors qu'on attendait impatiemment
l'armistice
ils sont morts jusqu'au dernier moment
e
le dernier moment n'est pas encore venu
à berlin le 2 octobre 1918 un
officiellement entre au reichstag
il est envoyé par le quartier-maître
général ludendorff
son nom baron a rich man m.bush le
message qu'ils apportent glace les
députés le quartier-maître général
averti le reichstag qu'il n'a plus de
réserve qu'il ne faut plus songer à
gagner la guerre les allemands sont
effondrées pendant des années on leur en
imposer le respect de l'état major
et voilà que l'état-major annoncent au
suicide au reichstag le reichstag décide
d'envoyer un représentant à l'armée il
désigne immédiatement comme chancelier
du rech
un cousin du désert le prince max de bad
il est chargé expressément de demander
un armistice le dender pense qu'on
obtiendra de meilleurs conditions en
s'adressant préalablement à washington
sans consulter les français ni les
britanniques aussi le prince max de
badens voit-il son appel aux américains
mais le président wilson peut-il décider
de répondre seul à une offre d'armistice
sans consulter ses alliés qui ont fait
la guerre pendant quatre ans j'ai subi
d'atroces et braz
les pourparlers se poursuivent pendant
que les soldats exténué décembre encore
aux tranchées quatre semaines se passe
ainsi dans l'incertitude
un quart de millions d'américains
attendent leur embarquement où naviguent
sur l'atlantique pendant qu'on négocie
mais enfin les cas dans le tome plus
guère et c'est pour les poilus une
consolation au même s'ils se font encore
tués dans des opérations ponctuelles
nous sommes au quartier général allemand
de spa en octobre 1918 le dender fa
temps les réponses aux messages de max
de bad demandant la paix négociée dont
la reddition sans condition de l'armée
allemande
le premier mot du président wilson est
un refus il ne veut pas discuter avant
que les allemandes et évacué la france
et la belgique
le thunder voulait négocier voilà qu'il
reçoit un ultimatum
il se retourne vers le kayser et
hindenburg il leur explique qu'il faut
continuer la guerre même contre la marée
montante de la défaite
si l'on veut sauver l'armée allemande la
marée et gagne les balkans l'armée serbe
rentrer chez elle et célèbre son retour
à belgrade après trois ans d'exil
la marée monte dans le proche orient
damas est abandonnée par les germano
turque à la cavalerie du désert de
lawrence d'arabie sur leurs talons
surgissent les soldats de l'armée d'alan
b qui ont reconquis la palestine et qui
sont désormais en syrie
laurence installés dans la ville de
damas
le nationalisme arabe en la personne du
prince pétales
tous les rêves ces impérialistes ont
fait long feu et surtout le rêve du
désert le chemin de fer de bagdad
les navires alliés entreront en
conquérant dans constantinople nargue
hommes l'effort de gallipoli les navires
sont lourdes tour elle qui craignait des
obus des canons allemands ils
franchiront sains et saufs les
dardanelles
voici le rêve autrichien de fédérations
des balkans de descente vers la mer
libre du sud
en italie les alliés préparent leur
offensive sur les alpes ils concentrent
leurs tirs sur l'autriche le plus faible
alliés d'allemagne les soldats blancs
pire quand ils sont des tchèques des
slovènes ou des croates se rendent par
milliers empire austro-hongrois est en
train de s'écrouler de l'intérieur les
nationalistes tiennent la rue dans la
capitale de la bohème la république
libre de tchécoslovaquie est proclamée à
prague
la splendeur des apps pour mener plus
qu'un souvenir
l' empire disparaît en proclamation on
proclame la république libre de hongrie
à budapest le programmateur est un
aristocrate socialiste michel caroli
la défaite irrémédiable touche les
alliés du désert les uns après les
autres dans les balkans la bulgarie la
turquie et l'autriche
le dernier front qui tiennent et celui
de l'ouest
l'offensive combiné des alliés est déjà
parti anglais et belges au nord français
au centre et américains dans la région
mozart gones pour prendre dans une passe
l'armée allemande en retraite
il n'y a pas de course haut rhin mais
une retraite allemand bien maîtrisé une
retraite vers la frontière ou ludendorff
compte s'arrêtait pour négocier la paix
le mouvement de retraite est plus lent
dans le secteur américain n'a frontières
les plus proches et la voie de sortie
plus étroite pour l'armée allemande
mais des milliers de soldats choisissent
de se rendre sans plus attendre
dans l'armée allemande les blessés ont
des bandages qui ont déjà servi des sous
vêtements confectionnés avec le linge de
table des hôtels du front nord mais
allemande souffre encore plus des
privations que les familles à
l'intérieur de l'allemagne
avec l'avancée des alliés des villages
français sont ré occupés par leurs
habitants
il pleure devant leur maison brûler
bombarder
spectacle émouvant que celui du prince
albert roi des belges
retrouvant sa patrie sa cage et à la
tête de l'armée qui a refusé de céder à
la force
en 1914
les allemands sont contraints d'évacuer
tous les territoires s'allier le
reichstag n'a pas le choix ils redoutent
une révolution bolchevique
il décide d'accepter des termes 2005 le
gouvernement mais palud est d'or et les
alliés préférerais que l'armée allemande
capitule
les agniers s'impatiente à l'hôtel
trianon à versailles le colonel house
envoyé spécial de wilson ne peut leur
donner tous les apaisements qu'il
demande
il est vrai que le président américain a
formulé un programme de paix en 14
points
il prétend imposer la construction d'une
ligue des nations une sorte de paix
perpétuelle pour tous les états d'europe
ce programme est aussi éloignée possible
de la paix deux victoires d'un
clemenceau et clemenceau veulent d'abord
des sécurités pour la france wilson est
aussi bien loin de la paix impérialistes
un orlando ou de la paix des réparations
exigées par lloyd george lord george
décide de câbles et à washington
il demande à wilson des éclaircissements
pas question qu'il fasse nappe est tout
seul
le 25 octobre 1918 l'oracle tombe wilson
ne veut pas traiter avec l'allemagne
militaire avec le kaiser
il ne veut plus de monarque à berlin
le gender s'engage une partie de bras de
fer avec hertz derrière le leader du
reichstag militaires et civils se
repasse le mauvais rôle
aucun d'eux veut signer hersberger se
décide pourtant refusant la capitulation
militaire le dender fin démissionner
hersberger s'adresse à foch directement
dans l'armée allemande le bruit court
qu'il a trahie dans la nuit du 7
novembre des 218 la délégation allemande
franchi les lignes dans un convoi
automobile arborant le drapeau blanc à
cliron français ouvrant la route
la délégation grimpe dans un wagon
aménagés en bureaux dans les boîtes
compiègne pour accueillir tous les
plénipotentiaires ce wagon entre dans
l'histoire
la clairière de rethondes devient le
lieu symbolique de la victoire alliée
contre l'allemagne
la délégation alliés se compose de deux
amiraux britannique de deux généraux
français foch président
les allemands demandent des propositions
elles sont très fermes retraite au delà
du rhin occupation alliés en allemagne
le blocus anglais continue jusqu'à la
signature du traité
horrifié les allemands demandent un
délai
une fuite permettent un journaliste
américain ron howard d'annoncer
prématurément la nouvelle de
l'acceptation de la bague il reste
encore du temps au front pour que les
soldats se fassent tuer rien n'est signé
e